so this talk addresses basically this
version perfect introduction thank you
because it addresses I always think if I
talk about technical stuff I try to say hey
me and my team how what did we encounter in the
first place because we all start with things oh
that's really simple there's a nice tutorial
let's get this started and we have like uh
um a hello world or something working like five
minutes and all the rest that comes afterwards so
this talk is based on use cases so use cases
around data hubs around data services around
building domain-driven data service clients
around it on premise for the cloud mixed
and of course a lot of migration as probably
some of you will already have guests already
um we also cover like inclusive access so business
there's also like these business users with Excel
that should be covered as well and microservices
and of course FastAPI is a very uh popular choice
nowadays and many people follow just like why
choose FastAPI and I'm lazy so this is what GPT
told me and I know chatGTP and I I now double
check facts and then double check the facts and
it was accurate so um it's fast it's the first
it's the first web framework I think also part
of the success of FastAPI is it's very similar to
the design of flask which was also very popular
in the python Community already and FastAPI just
took it things to another level um so it it was a
really fast growing project as well it gives us a
very scalable flexible architecture for building
things but as Max said in the introduction
you start with it you think it's easy and
I would like to introduce you to some use cases
Solutions and things you probably don't need to
stumble across as we did I'm Alexander I'm part
managing partner at Königsweg we have a booth
outside come by with PlayStation to win um oh now
now now I've got you I'm also part of multiple
python ecosystem zero python this conference for
me community and knowledge exchange is very very
important and if you want to discuss things with
me come talk to me I also have to do a disclaimer
because some parts might be a bit opinionated
or exaggerated I want to have a full disclaimer
um I still love FastAPI so it's not like
a talk why not to use API just like to how
can we make use of API FastAPI better and also
it's a very active community and I especially
also want to thank everybody who contributed
code tutorials whatever in the ecosystem and
I think Sebastian is doing an amazing job
as organizing and enabling this community
let me introduce you to a prototypical FastAPI
Journey there's a requirement FastAPI utilizes
the open API standard which has been established
for many years so if you don't have haven't heard
about it just like a quick preview this is like
these nice Pages where people have documentation
generated from code on web pages so you can
interact and understand the API way easier
um this is also I would say an industry standard
nowadays and of course you look for framework
very likely you sample of course fast Aid and
nowadays there used to be others like I also like
connection but unfortunately that was neglected
for some time and FastAPI just is now a bit better
um you can do like a hello world in five minutes
and it gets you going really fast and of course
of soon you say okay I only need to know FastAPI
because this solves all my problems this is like
a typical mistake humans engineers I do oh that
sounds really great I've never tried it it's
must be just so good and perfect and it promises
everything and you can build stuff on tutorial at
a time and this is how many people start to use
FastAPI and some next steps on that journey of
course you want to add more endpoints you want
to add more request models your desk response
models you want to have contracts you want
to make sure everybody talks to your API and
standardized well-readable easy to understand
fashion and of course you also want to you
say okay this is the feedback you're going
to get and here's the documentation for it
and of course once you get started you have more
complex models you want to validate data you want
to be consistent and consistent in naming and of
course of course operation stuff like middleware
for logging or contacts like correlation IDs
and on and on and some challenges I found
on on that Journey was when we were working on
it you just don't basically need to know FastAPI
FastAPI is more than just FastAPI Pydantic
is a very big part of FastAPI under the hood
Starlet is a really good big part under
the hood UV cone for running the servers
um so you have to be aware that one challenge is
everything is solved by just like another layer of
obstruction so it's basically like like an onion
which is deeper and deeper and deeper and it's
all really well implemented it all works really
well together but it's not it's usually like you
really have to you're not really sure which which
framework is responsible now for this and that
um it's very packed um and of course you need
to think about designing sustainable endpoints
that are understandable you want to think about
your modeling also like how can you enable your
organization by these models because building one
service for small team is easy but once you have
a definition dumb you want others in other
departments also to use it and not to have
them reinvent other models and this actually also
already starts with hey is that ID is that asset
ID and all these tiny questions that need to be
answered um and so the summary is not a summary
of the talks or summaries so what I want to talk
about today is FastAPI is built this is built on
the shoulders of giants in two or two to two par
top two feel about it and create tutorials but
is this documentation from a middleware use case
and also how not to repeat yourself with Pydantic
and I really want to start with Pydantic
because I think Pydantic who knows Pydantic
well almost everyone yeah like working hard so
let me introduce everyone who isn't familiar
with Pydantic yet Pydantic you can build models
you can Define models with Pydantic so it's very
similar to data classes um it's which is basically
up it's so it's it's you can also like as metal
models say this is like an improved data class
so bad data classes with extras or benefits it's
really easy to Define an endpoint as we see above
here like have a response model asset and asset
is just defined as a class that has an asset ID
a name and a currency code and this is just like
being used by Pydantic already to generate
so for example the documentation which we
already saw in the open API standard so actually
Pydantic does a lot of the heavy lifting it's
it's uh it parses the input data and and I think
there's also like a often very understood if I
don't think is understood here with because it
parses the data so still if you give a list of
integers of strings there which can be passed
to an integer you Pydantic will make a list
of integers there so it's not validating no
sorry please I'm expecting a list of integers
just from scratch um because it's still built to
work in rest slash web applications and of course
if you send something to a server as a Json or
via URL or query parameters of course a query
parameter is always text so and of course Pydantic
takes the text and parses it and said okay yeah
that's the list my composite it and enter just
all good but it will not complain if you send
something which is uh yeah it will not complain
if you always send something that can be parsed
in an integer just like it's a very simple and
basic example so it does not validate aggressively
it seems okay it looks good and I can I can
basically transform it into the target format
and there's many misunderstandings with
Pydantic for example so it's really easy to
build a model to add documentation I kept it
short so it fits on the slides of course you
can do way better and descriptions what what
is inside give example data which are again
in displayed in the open API standard so it's
very good to make people understand what what
which data models do we expect Which models do you
return what structures do you return and respect
and for example like the validator validator
costs I think a few hours of Lifetime with many
developers because I think validators are not the
optimal name for that because the validator is you
can add a validator to validate asset ID here and
we just want to validate is it is it an integer
um between 0 and 999 and my expectation was hey
it's a validator and if the assert doesn't raise
all good it's a validator right so because I've
also worked with other validator Frameworks as
um severals before and actually if servers
said no it's not an integer it raises but
here actually we get a none returned so for the
validator you always have to you can do land
many checks you can use it for data mangling
or cleansing which is really handy as well
um so what you really need to know okay if
you want not something like none back or
not not Mac you have to return the original
value if it passes all tests and um yeah so
it's a great feature once you understand it
and we will hear a bit more about it later
another good thing is to know Pydantic defaults
um Pydantic comes with from well
chosen built in defaults but you
should not just you should be aware of them
um I just give you a very simple use case
imagine we have our rest API defined with response
and request models so we basically know which data
or how the state the Json in this case has to
be structured when we send it off to the back
end and of course we have a return here so what
happens there was a front-end developer and said
oh I have this new feature requests and I just add
something extra to the Json and everybody said hey
cool we have models we are basically safe because
like if something does not really fit to the back
end the back end will raise a validation error
but in this case it didn't has anybody an idea why
yes
yes correct you didn't restrict the model because
the the um the default in this case here is extra
um I don't know it's not it's just like to allow
extra attributes and if an attribute you send to
your request model is not just known it's just
ignored and this was happened here so the front
of the designer said okay well funnel developer
said hey cool I don't get a complaint from the
back end team nobody noticed because there was no
exception nothing until people realized oh okay
um somewhere in the business code also
no value was given they use the default
um and of course it didn't really work as expected
and nobody was able to notice it so I think it's
very important so I my suggestion is always to uh
not to use uh extra allow to reuse extra forbid
to be I'm more like hey let's make contracts that
Define the models they find it more in a strict
fashion because sometimes or very often teams were
distributed and with extra forbid you're in the
safe Zone it's a design decision so if you like
python code with a lot of star double star quarks
and pass it around through many other methods
or classes this then please do extra allow but
if you're more like like to design which
is more well defined extra for a bit I
think it's better for teams and especially if
you build critical business um applications
this was the first part about identity
field we'll come back to Pydantic later
the next giant I really want to mention and
promote is Starlet actually so what is Starlet
Starlet this is just copied from the Starlet um
website so style it is a lightweight framework
um and you already see like oh HTTP background
task startup and shutdown events um and responses
um session cookie support you see there's
many features FastAPI exposes also directly
via FastAPI but you see it's all basically it
comes from Starlet under the hood so I think it's
very important to not give all like a shout out
because I think style that they did an amazing job
um but I think it's also like a very
good practice to look into the Starlet
documentation and to know better what what
is happening here how Starlet handles things
so this is like a simple stalet example so you
build a middleware we add middleware for example
for context um to to follow up on requests for
logging filtering stuff allowing things it's
just like a generic example and then you already
see like there's a ad app on event startup you see
okay it's a startup when we basically can imagine
from just what I read on the slide before hey this
is just like a wrapper who takes you to stalet
from FastAPI and and one use case we really had
to go deeper here um I want to summarize it real
short so um we built an interface to a data Hub
um the data client is supposed to be a convenient
self-explanatory interface so check FastAPI with
all the documentation every single text
is a very good choice but we also want to
um well we build a data client around it so data
client means that's this example with client dot
portfolio Benchmark just like a simple function
a business user can easily remember and use this
code completion to say Okay I want to compare two
portfolios this is a finance boost use case and I
have one portfolio I want to compare and I have
a benchmark and a benchmark if none is just like
default Benchmark which belongs to the portfolio
um that's a very simple interaction there so
um FastAPI the data Hub uses FastAPI we have
a easy simple endpoint portfolio Benchmark and
a request model IDE Benchmark and so how can we
generate the client automatically what's the first
question and okay to sum this up in the use
case there's some Auto generators but they
did not meet any of our expectations in coding
standards redundancy also are in terms of uh
yeah like many python object connections which
is lost because you generate code again from the
yaml and you don't have a direct connection to the
python code which we were actually looking for so
um the solution was actually to render the client
ourselves with Ginger 2 which worked really well
um and but the other issue was that we had some
path parameters so if you put something in the
URL as query parameters or to send data and um the
model parameters which you can post in adjacent so
we wanted there were some ambiguities we wanted to
solve that was a harder task and we were asking a
question can we fix it somehow in the middleware
and this took us to the journey to enabling user
with simplifying interfaces with middleware um
so my suggestion is don't try this at home um
so it was a spike story to inspect how can the
middleware help to mangle requests within the
um the middleware um to moderate data to make the
interface easier for business users especially and
we found out it's very complex and and and hard
to to find um it's solvable but it's not as easy
as you think because there's many things that
are not clear how actually the inner mechanics
work because a thing here is we miss a lot of
documentation around here and this brings me to
the next topic so um there's great tutorials
with FastAPI and the ecosystem around it but
where are the doc strings and so I counted the dog
strings for FastAPI I think that's one of the most
more recent version so FastAPI has 6 000 lines I
even counted the empty lights it has 259 classes
and 429 functions or methods and I only
was able to identify 11 dock strings so
is that a good number for Doc strings in oh no
I hear disagreement from the from the audience
the design of Jose is with many layers of
instruction so even if you work in a debugger
so we would we really love to work to use the
debugger to see what's really happening where
is what is happening where just find out with
a debugger to to to to correct the use case but
sometimes it's or very often it was really
hard because there's no dog string to give
you a hint you're here you hear this is
happening here it's basically just like a
functions with names and this is really hard to
find but also to I checked for Starlet actually
um it's that's the wrong numbers let's get
that um I can tell you in the break I put on
my computer so uh yeah so it's I think it's a
call for more dog strings I don't know why are
there are so few dark strings because around it
there's many tutorials great documentation but
if you really want to see something in context
that's really hard um another very good learning
was don't repeat yourself with Pydantic because of
course you start to build models like the assets
you there's more models coming in there's more
definition the whole the whole thing grows um so
this is just like a little reminder for everyone
who's not familiar with Pydantic yet this is it's
a very simple model but as you see for example in
the next slide you could also abstract it further
like to say okay we just have one model for the
asset ID because we want to make sure every model
who contains the para the asset ID um should use
the same and we just want to re reuse it because
we don't want to rewrite repetitive examples
because writing your examples is not as easy as
you think and it's just like quite boring as well
so you can abstract this into into multiple layers
like here and to for consistency for reusability
um I'm I'm a strong believer in don't repeat
yourself try Computing so make sure everything
in your code you only there's only one one line
to fix things or to update and this brings us
to Pydantic inheritance which is also a little
bit I would we found it like counter-intuitive
like um so we have decomposed everything here
into smaller pieces so we see we added a period
which is from to date asset name and we all can
basically compose it together in the compose
class here asset asset ID and period and so
we now have a model with four attributes this is
really nice it's clean it really helps we decided
to build an internal package around it and to make
it available to multiple other in-house libraries
but of course identic inheritance has also like a
little danger zone for example here I updated the
validator we saw earlier with a star so star says
here well it does a star has please validate each
and every attribute but it's not the instruction
please on validate each and every attribute only
of the class where I reside basically this is
also inherited and if you have this validator
in inheritance it will try to validate everything
and fun fact not everything is an integer and
this is basically also misleading it's not another
thing is Pydantic gives great exceptions readable
exceptions but sometimes it's really hard
if something art happens to find out what
is actually happening and where's the oddness and
sometimes it points a bit on the wrong wrong side
so um to sum up the use case defining models
for an entire organization was introduced and
to introduce and enable with standardization I'm
a big fan of standardization standardizing things
and discussing things up front and building
a nice architecture bringing everybody on
board especially departments uh from the um from
from the business know-how side um it's really
important to have clear and concise design rules
including naming conventions and of course you
can centralize but also lessons weren't was you
can do too much centralization so it's really
good to have stuff like asset something which is
basically used and repeated everywhere and in many
other libraries it's very good to centralize them
but you shouldn't be too dogmatic about it because
um it's okay if another service defines its own
models reusing stuff from the core Library thank
you and um and and yeah it's easier to Define
cross-organization attributes which are like a
very important core and others you can Define
yourself and you need also somebody who takes
these calls and decisions in the team it's uh it
should be just not between the development teams
because this can be heated um you need somebody
to coordinate but also to promote hey we have
this please use this I mean what's this usually
decentralized organizations and many companies now
um I also want to notice five things I love
for the first API not only like complaining and
pointing I think the accessibility in general
due to the design pattern of another layer of
extraction is great it's it's you can really see
what's happening until you get lost um missing dog
strings a dynamic creation of routers is great
custom validation for array handling is awesome
middleware is easy to add and the fifth thing
is actually five more things I mean it has many
great features so um yeah and I think I have like
one minute left and I can take you to the bonus
you can also render open eye API instincts
if you use Sphinx documentation you don't
necessarily need to have a server running up to
the open API page here you can just like include
it into your documentation so all you need is the
things contribute open API extension you can add
it to the things extensions just like any other
things extension um the important things here are
you need to export your open eye definition
to a yaml file for example that's built in
in fast APA already and guess what's
the latest hand so that is handling it
and you have to edit of course to your index and
another thing and this is like the output here
um you can just like add this page to your
documentation and things publish it on the
website you don't need to have a server running
to interact things and then I thought this was
really useful and helpful and nice and one
more pointer here is you also need to add
this Dev setup somewhere in your app if that's
missing it's not taking the connection that's
um that's something you just have to know but
friendly people on stack Overflow referenced here
have published published it all
right um thank you very much um
awesome thank you so much that's really
interesting talk and it's really been
great to hear your perspective as well can I
add something please do yes I want to thank
my colleagues and peers mentioned here on
the slides yeah because this is all team
efforts and learnings and very useful
discussions um yeah and also thanks
for Lambda labs for putting the model
online on hugging face for the images
okay great so I've just got some questions that
have just come in now and so I've got quite a
few to ask you we've got my three minutes so
we'll do what we can and we might be able to
run over very slightly because it is lunch next
you're also one I'm around run fast and far
um first question here um did you
consider using flask or API flask
instead of FastAPI at any time during
this project no no easy questions okay
um how should you handle mapping between different
application layers and the question is how should
you handle mapping between different application
layers oh yeah we're actually like between
application our solution was to say to build a
library and publicize it internally but that's
not as easy as the thing sure yeah it's a lot
of it's basically more coordination than uh
coding problem sure fair enough um so another
question here from Anonymous who writes in
um to ask the question what do you think of
the robustness principle that states we should
be liberal in what we accept but conservative
in what we send considering the forbid option
well as I pointed out earlier I think in
business applications I'm rather say let's
define how we talk and the protocol like on
which data structures we accept and which data
structures we will respond but I'm I know that
are as many use cases where flexibility is is
is more is better for the project it actually I
think it depends on the business use case and if
it's just like okay we can ignore it and all is
fine it's good I mean I like to work efficient
and this is for many use cases probably a more
efficient way but in the space where we use work
is we have to be like super reliable yeah because
mistakes there in backends can be expensive yeah I
think a question that we generally ask as well is
what's the cost of fixing a bug and that generally
so a few more questions for you and a
few more coming in um one here and this
is actually one I had as well so thank you
to Anonymous for asking that one great work
um is uh so you chose to use a Pydantic
inheritance rather than composing models
um I've definitely so I use Pydantic in
my day job and I've definitely got into
composing model hell where I end up composing
something which is made up of models and models
and models like why why was it why did
you choose to do it the way that you did
I actually was work in progress so starting
starting bring a team on also at the client
one model at a time and then we thought okay
there's a lot of repetition and so we decided for
inheritance there's also multiple other ways you
can even build models just like from code or jaml
definitions but we decided against that in this
case because for us a call complication in the IDE
is very important and we don't really want stuff
to be generated yeah we found the same actually
uh generating from a very complicated open API
spec wasn't again actually we also found out you
can really generate code with ginger too it's
really good so I'm a big fan of code generating
at home now yeah so okay got some more questions
we have some more ones about the talk but there
is one that's overwhelmingly been upvoted which
is where are you getting those awesome pictures
from memory address or you know artist name
please uh oh actually the artist's name yeah
that's an interesting thing so actually this is
the stable diffusion model uh from uh from Lambda
Labs I found it on hugging phase so it's a public
model uh so I said that thanks for sharing all of
the labs and uh actually as every image generator
it's a little bit more like the challenge is now
not to generate images just to put in the right
keywords and actually so the artist keyword I put
in there was Max Ernst which is a German serialist
so and Mark's amps worked really well because
photorealistic pictures don't they are locked
like well not really presentable yeah but Max
Ernst and serialism really worked great uh but
I'm yeah if you know other talks for me I used
to do style transfer for like five six seven
years now and this is a new technologies but
I had some transfer from arts and yeah so I had
some names in my head diggurira also works great
but when God also works great but it's always
starry night that's the problem because there's
too much bias in the models that would make sense
actually um there's a few more questions coming in
um so you know you are free to leave lunch
might be served at some point but I'm going
to keep asking them as long as Alexander here is
happy to answer yeah there's lunch downstairs so
I might see a mad rush but um question here um
actually one that's just been upvoted to the
top where can I find your slides oh I can publish
them later on Discord that was my plan um awesome
Twitter Discord or Twitter or alternatively
I'm sure you'll be around for the rest of the
conference people I'm around also if you have a
question or if you want to connect yes you just
there's a QR code just connect on LinkedIn and
I'm happy to give you some guidance if needed
a few more questions uh what's a good practice
if you want to share the Pydantic models that
you've created with with your teams for example
or python back in with a reference and then you
want to integrate like how do you find that
process is for you no actually like our way
was to publicize internal models but you
also need an infrastructure for that sure
um yeah so but I think you could accomplish
the same just like by sharing a library on a
repo because it's really easy so that's that's
another really handy thing to know if you are
those models and you want to share you can
also just pip minus E install them so even if
you make a new pull request you don't need
to reinstall it with Pip it automatically
um updates whatever you updated because like
compiling and setting up everything is sometimes
time consuming yeah because one of the challenges
here is actually there's a model update and
some but you're working on something else in the
application and somebody else does a model update
and then things keeping things in this thing is
with the centralization that's that's an issue
um so it's that's a good work around
it especially when you start ramping
things up like once you have low extrapolation
standards and libraries and everything builds
up because it's this is just like a process and
it will take some time and then until you have a
certain amount of stability but in the ramping
up phase it's really handy also to use install
sure we have a few more questions but I think it's
best to maybe let everyone go for lunch now so um
you know and there are if there are questions you
can find Alex yeah I'm at the clinic Swig pools
with the PlayStation thank you very much thank
you very much thank you thank you thank you